[Music]
that's a scene from filmmakers jordan
peele's latest movie it's called nope
and you got to say it just like that
nope it debuted at number one over the
weekend thank you very much bringing 44
million dollars at the box office that's
big peel's first horror film get out won
him an oscar for best original
screenplay we all remember that one we
sat down with the writer director ahead
of knope's release the other day to talk
about what he calls his most ambitious
film yet
before we start you said you have two
poses that you look good this is one
this is one okay and what what is that
look saying that look at saying i don't
care okay whatever you know whatever
whatever you think okay in the most high
status way okay whatever you think and
what's your second pose
and what does that say this is whatever
i think whatever you know what i'm
saying
jordan peel's comedic roots run deep oh
man that's bad luck
steal that emily george
nice to meet you but now with the
release of the director's third feature
film titled nope it's a bad miracle
it's undeniable for peel horror feels
like home
first and foremost i wanted to make a
ufo horror film and
and then of course it's like where are
you know where is the iconic black ufo
film
and whenever i
feel that there's um
my favorite movie out there that hasn't
been made
you know that's the void i'm trying to
fill with my my films it's like trying
to make the film that i wish someone
would make for me
i like to surprise people and i like to
shock i like to provoke people who are
in for a good provoking i love
the audience and i love
feeling like the audience is wrapped or
they're
they're together in on something i just
love that at points i was cringing i was
wincing i was laughing i was confused
i felt such a
combination of emotions is that what you
want
that's like the best review to me is it
you want to take us on that kind of
journey yes there's a spectrum
of moods that kind of amounts to this
film and i just love
films that have done that for me
and i also just love films that you know
have moments and things in them that
just
what i call like smack you in the head
with a
a bag of bricks
you know where you just didn't see
something coming but a bag of bricks
jordan kills people when you smack them
in the head they are dead sometimes but
if they you know survive they're happy
nope follows the lives of siblings in
the horse training business who suddenly
find themselves looking up
it's something out of this
so i do want to be in your brain what is
happening up there what is your your
your thought process
in this particular movie what was it i
wrote it you know i wrote it in a time
that where i feel like most of us feel
like we've been living through a bad
miracle and i just said you know look my
this my job is to be
is to process this through the only way
i know how
and to use my imagination and to use my
my nightmares and and to try and
um
you know make sense of the world around
me do you like to be scared i don't like
to be scared jordan peele do you like to
be scared i'm always scared
i mean yeah and i think we can all agree
that it is a scary world so
i i do feel like we need these outlets
to face our fears
we just need it yeah and so i i like to
put us in a position where we're safe
where we're together and we don't just
feel the fear we can feel the fun we can
feel the adventure we can feel the love
and and the joy as well but you also say
it's important to balance it in
particular you said with black joy
yeah as i've i've sort of dedicated
a lot of energy to telling stories about
black horror
and
you know realizing that you know there's
only so much black horror needed
in this world of where there's so much
real black horror
and that my responsibility also becomes
okay we have to transcend that as well
we have to
tell a story about black joy because i
haven't seen that enough either and so
when these two things get together you
have nope
and i'm i'm very proud of it i love the
title nope because we all go nope
well how did you come up with that title
what does it mean to you because you
could have called it nah
nah because that's what kiki said a lot
now on the hand yeah
no no no
well i had to change up the note we
can't just say you know we say nope a
lot in the movie but yeah you know
sometimes it's going to be no no hell no
oh see no no that's one of my favorites
is c no see where the c comes first you
called it nope y
i because uh i wanted to acknowledge
first of all that the film is different
it's not it's not a film i feel like
that sort of accepts a more traditional
title it's kind of a concept in itself
we know that you can do comedy very well
we know that you can direct we know that
you also like horror do you have a
preference for one over the other when
it comes to comedy or comedy or horror
yeah you know i
i think
i
i love it when they both can intermingle
when both of those tones can exist at
the same time they make each other
better
the you know you're scared and you are
so ready to laugh you're so ready to be
have that tension released
nope also reunites jordan peele and
daniel kaluuya who first worked together
on get out the eyes of daniel kaluuya
daniel's expressions yes are so
important and to for this character and
for this story because it is a story
about spectacle and how we observe
spectacle and our addiction to it and so
daniel can just do so much with
saying very little
and let's talk about kiki palmer okay
pull the tape because i saw this the
other day and i said this is so her to
me getting ready for the release of note
mom what are you thinking this time i'm
with my mom you guys i am so excited i
cannot wait to see it looking at this
gorgeous poster
but it's like dreams come true
she has such a wonderful support system
that is around her and she's just a
absolute treasure in this film do you
feel pressure from the industry in the
position that you're in because now
so far and i predict this is going to do
very well that would make it three for
three for you well thank you do you feel
pressure
in your position there's pressure but
i just have to um
you know i i just really focus on how
lucky i am i always have to just take a
moment take a breath get some
perspective i'm i'm living my my dream
here what was your dream
director i was yes that was my dream
that is yeah that is my dream i'm
getting to do that
yeah i was surprised it wasn't to be an
actor it wasn't to be a comedian it's to
be an actor even though he's good at
those other things now he's very good at
those other things you know he said he
wrote the part with kiki in mind we get
you'll get that when you see the movie
and he calls daniel kahlua is like his
um
uh de niro to his scorsese because he's
yeah because they're like now work
together he said they have a shorthand
when they work and daniel's uh name in
the movie is oj which stands for otis jr
that was intentional too because he says
he chose the name because that name oj
has its own relationship to spectacle
and toxicity of intention the layers i
know there is there's so many little
easter eggs and so many layers to the
movie what does he want to do next he
said he wouldn't mind doing a children's
film i said you want to scare the
children now he has a son he goes no but
he does believe at this stage he can do
any genre it's just a matter of deciding
what that is but he really really loves
being a director and the movie and he
likes it when you're confused number one
you got to see it on a big screen
unfortunately i had to watch it on my uh
laptop so i i think that hurts the
experience you've got to see this movie
on imax on a big screen because it will
scare you it'll make you laugh it'll
take you on quite a ride i think he is
so cool
i do too
he's emotionally intelligent he's he's
keenly aware of what he wants and what
his audience needs right he just seems
like he's in a very good place and that
right there is the definition we were
talking about this the other day where i
just love the notion of he was known he
came to be known for comedy but then he
said you know i'm more than the sum of
the things that you've seen me do and
let me show you what i can do and
probably people said well no you're a
comedian yeah you're a funny guy you
want to come out and do this horror
movie and he said let me show you what i
can do and bam yeah we don't key and
peel but they're going to do some other
things together he said their
relationship is still tight